bonsoir Monsieur Vincent on vient de le
voir vous avez plusieurs doléances
qu'est-ce que vous dire les dirigeants
PME qu'est-ce qu'ils aimeraient entendre
dans les prochains jours et par exemple
au débat des chefs de ce soir mais ils
aimeraient entendre les
dirigés les chefs de parties sur les
préoccupations là sur la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre sur la fiscalité on a entendu
beaucoup parler de taxes des citoyens de
baisse d'impôts mais on parle pas que la
fiscalité des petites entreprises des
avantages au Québec au Canada que 30%
plus de taxes sur la masse salariale ici
que les plus petites entreprises des
secteurs des services et de la
construction même pas accès au taux
d'impôts réduit qui paye un impôt de
259% plus élevé de de la paperasse puis
la PME c'est le quart de l'économie donc
si on veut avoir une économie
florissante il faut parler au dirigeants
de PME du Québec là vous venez de me
parler d'impôts puisque vous l'évoquez
parlons-en pour les particuliers
effectivement on a promis des bases
d'impôts dans certains cas on a vu des
montagnes évoqués 2000 dollars etc
est-ce que vous
l'équivalent ou même plus pour les PME
qu'est-ce que vous demandez concrètement
mais le minimum ça serait que on a une
réflexion sur l'affaire official du
Québec on est la seule province au
Canada qui impose plus les petites
entreprises parce qu'elles sont petites
dans les secteurs des services et de la
construction au départ ça a été faite en
2015 pour créer de l'emploi mais là ils
sont même pas capable d'embaucher des
personnes puis elle se retrouve à être
pénalisée fiscalement j'étais à
Trois-Rivières hier j'ai rencontré des
entrepreneurs je veux un entrepreneur
qui fonctionne six mois par année il y a
une petite boutique sur la rue des
Forges mais lui qui fasse beau qu'il
fasse pas beau il peut voir son taux
d'impôts explosif 259%, la seule
province au Canada que cette injustice
jusqu'à là il y a eu 26 groupes
économiques qui ont demandé des
changements le 3/4 de la population qui
était d'accord le minimum ça serait de
regarder comment on peut améliorer la
fiscalité des entreprises au Québec pour
permettre la croissance des petites
entreprises bon vous souhaitez également
parler de main d'oeuvre on en a parlé
quand même de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
depuis le début de la campagne plusieurs
des parties ont proposé leur cible pour
l'immigration par exemple est-ce que ça
va assez loin ce qui a été proposé à
votre avis il faut plus de mesures il
faut reconnaître que la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre là on n'est pas sorti du bois
le petit de mauvaise nouvelle puis il
faut serrer les coudes en tant que
société j'avais écrit une lettre ouverte
là-dessus le 23 mai pour dire faut en
faire un enjeu de société il faut pas
juste voir le bon côté de la médaille au
niveau de l'augmentation des salaires ça
prend une série de mesures il faut
adapter les mesures un peu comme pendant
la covid les gouvernements étaient
capables d'adapter leur programme pour
sauver les PME mais ça prend oui des
mesures en immigration puis peu importe
le chiffre dans les 100 premiers jours
on devrait tenir la commission sur le
plan Trianon d'immigration avoir les
experts du Québec puis augmenter
l'immigration Québec ça prend une
diminution de fardeau fiscale les PME
c'est la première chose qu'elle demande
pour les aider pour augmenter les
salaires pour automatiser ça prend des
programmes qui sont mieux desservis pour
la petite entreprise parce que la
première conséquence la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre c'est que les dirigeants de
l'entreprise travaillent plus d'heures
donc moins de temps de chercher
on est à 30% de plus de taxes sur la
masse à l'arrière donc le gouvernement
peut en parler puis dire comment il va
aider le dirigeant de la petite
entreprise
vous avez échangé avec les dirigeants ou
des représentants de plusieurs parties
pour savoir quelles étaient leurs
propositions vous leur avez parlé ici
savent ce que vous demandez est-ce que
vous sentez que vous êtes écoutés et
entendu les PME aimeraient en entendre
plus là
80-78%, puis c'est plus important que la
perception qui avait au début c'était
69% je pense pas qu'ils vont parler de
nos enjeux puis là ça monte à 8 sur 10
faut leur parler au dirigeants
d'entreprise puis une élection là on
peut faire des promesses jusqu'à la fin
c'est comme le baseball c'est jamais
fini avant que ça soit fini donc ça peut
commencer ce soir quand on va parler
d'économie qu'on parle de la place des
petites et moyennes entreprises parce
que c'est elle qui génère les emplois au
Québec c'est elle qui génère la
croissance de nos régions qui assure
notre résilience économique là ça va
peut-être sembler cynique ce que je vais
vous demander mais est-ce que ce sont
elles qui génère les votes est-ce que
c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas autant de
promesses pour les entreprises que pour
les particuliers vous croyez peut-être
mais quand on regarde le nombre
d'emplois le 2/3 des emplois c'est en
PME que ça se retrouve faction on veut
une croissance économique mais faut
parler aux dirigeants d'entreprise il y
en a au-dessus de 200 250 000 si on veut
justement avoir un plan qui fonctionne
c'est c'est l'État peut donner certaines
orientations mais sur nos créateurs de
richesse c'est nos femmes et nos hommes
qui créent des entreprises partons en
région qui peuvent faire une différence
puis il reste du temps à l'élection puis
espérons que justement si la question de
l'une c'est l'économie la PME devrait
être centrale dans les propositions des
parties on verra si votre appel est
entendu merci beaucoup d'avoir été
l'homme monsieur Vincent merci de
l'invitation pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI